this is a production of Cornell
University all right hi everyone my name
is Angela I'm a PhD candidate in Michele
hex lab and today I'm gonna be telling
you a story from my dissertation about
citrus greening disease so citrus
greening disease or Wang long Bing is a
fatal disease of citrus and it causes
citrus fruits to ripen unevenly and
taste salty and bitter in the United
States it's caused by the gram-negative
bacterium called candidate aslim herb
actor Ozzy Atticus and I'm gonna be
calling that CLS now see last can be
transmitted between citrus hosts by an
insect called the Asian citrus psyllid
which you'll see here
this transmission relationship is
complex but really it begins with the
ability of the psyllid to feed on citrus
plants and that's what i'll focus on
today the psyllid is a committer an
insect much like aphids or white flies
and when it's feeding on citrus plants
it uses its piercing sucking mouth pull
mal parts called a stylet to pierce into
citrus tissue and so here you'll see a
cross-section of a citrus leaf and it's
been stained to show protein and you'll
see here these blue squiggles this is
evidence of where a cyllid has fed and
it uses its stylet to probe until it
finds ass phloem element now during
feeding a sheath polymerizes around the
psyllids stylet and its native salivary
secretions now here if we use an
electron micrograph we can view the
sheath and you'll see that it forms all
the way around the mouth part and it has
this globular structure now we know that
this sheath is made out of 90%
carbohydrates and 10% proteins and it is
essential for psyllid feeding so if this
structure cannot glimmer eyes the
psyllid cannot penetrate this is the
citrus tissue finally we know that it's
glamorization is inhibited by EDTA which
is a molecule that binds to metal ions
now I wanted to know what proteins were
present in the structure and so I used
proteomics to determine that strikingly
I only found three proteins abundant in
this structure and they were al a case
like multicopper oxidases a multi copper
oxidase and al a case with the predicted
copper binding moiety so this led me to
develop the hypothesis that copper might
be a critical metal
hi hon for the form and function of the
stylet sheath so I wanted to know if
copper itself could have a function or
an effect on the morphology of the
sheath and so I allowed psyllids to feed
on artificial diets within without
copper and here in the water containing
diet you'll see that the sheaths are
linear and they look similar to the
electron micrograph that I showed you
but with copper the sheets are dilated
and they have a higher incidence of this
multi branching phenotype so you could
imagine that this branching phenotype
could allow the Silla to access multiple
phloem cells at the same time or
subsequently now I wanted to know the
big question which was could copper
presence actually impact see last
transmission and so I did this
experiment where I took citrus leaves
and I soaked them with either water zinc
sulfate or copper sulfate and then I
allowed 10 C last infected insects to
feed on the leaves to inoculate the
bacteria for two days and then I took
the mid ribs the middle vein of each
leaf and then the psyllids feeding on it
and I extracted the DNA and did qpcr to
quantify the amount of C less present in
that sample and what I found was that
copper increased the transmission of C
laughs by the psyllid and interesting ly
highest level of copper actually was
able to decrease the level of bacteria
in the insect and I have hypotheses as
to why this may be and I'd love to
discuss them but what I want to leave
you with is that this could have huge
implications for growers based on my
personal communication with some growers
in Florida it's copper sulfate
containing pesticides are sprayed on all
citrus groves every two weeks so I think
this really opens up the possibility
that we could evaluate the effects of
metal containing pesticides on the
behavior and feeding of important
agricultural vectors so with that I'd
like to acknowledge my lab and our
collaborators at the USDA Fort Pierce
and I would be happy to take any
questions yeah yeah so the question was
did I test other populations of the
insect and could this insect have
evolved sort of a relationship seemingly
with conventional like a resistance
okay to copper yeah so I
I've only tested one population of these
insects but I think it's a really
interesting idea
however in Florida that kind of
population wouldn't be available because
typically every Grove has to be sprayed
continuously with pesticides but it's
possible that some populations in
California for example might not have
been exposed and so that's an idea for
future work Chris did you have a
question yeah I think that's such an
exciting question so the question is is
the copper ingested into the psyllid
during feeding and so that I haven't
tested whether the copper actually gets
ingested but I know it's at high levels
in the plant and the phloem and so my
hypothesis is that it could be coppers
having an effect on the bacteria inside
the insect or it could be that perhaps
there's not a direct effect and that
actually as CLS reaches a higher titer
in the plant and therefore the insect it
actually causes gut cells to die and so
it could be that the gut cells are dying
and then seaglass is dying with them so
we know about see less causes
fragmentation in gut cells anyway so
those are my two possible hypotheses
which I think are really interesting to
test okay I think maybe I'm out of time
thank you this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at cornell
edu